where did you where did you get your
humor like i mean where did that come
from is it uh cultivated is it i mean
it's got to be a lot natural was your
dad funny your mom
my mom and dad aren't funny at all
oh well that's kind of funny actually
they would they'd probably be like what
i'm funny um no you're not um i i would
just say i think being the baby
of the bunch right so i'm the youngest
of three boys
i think i had to find humor
in things because it was just a lot of
mayhem right growing up with all three
of us um and so if there's any place
that it came from it would be just kind
of like i was the kid who just was like
yeah whatever and just i found the
you know i i've always been glass half
full kind of guy and i think that really
lends itself to my brand of comedy
whereas the there are the guys who and
women who are glass half empty and
that's the source of their comedy right
it comes from a dark place mine comes
from a very happy light
fun
you know enjoying life you know even
when things aren't good in my life i'm
still enjoying life and i think that
that
take on everything allows me to dive
deeper into just
trying to bring a lightness of fun a
happiness to every situation that i'm in
you know even if you're talking about a
serious situation i'm probably gonna
make a joke somewhere because i'd rather
everybody kind of light
and open than than not and i would say
that that i've used it mostly
in my life as a director
because when you're directing and
everybody's in the process and
everybody's trying to figure out what
they want to do and how they want to say
something sometimes that moment lighting
it up just just taking the pressure out
of the moment and putting it on me and
taking it away from everybody just
allows them to go oh and they breathe
and then all of a sudden i feel like
especially with younger people when i
was working for you know disney
they would they would absolutely give
you a better performance and the
performance would be just a lot happier
and lighter and especially with disney
channel you wanted that kind of energy
right where everybody felt light and i
felt like i was able to to really kind
of help with that lightness and and just
you know
when i when i read things when i hear
things uh i i
i connect it and i connect it to a lot
of the stuff that i always do it's all
regurgitated humor
something that i saw somebody i you know
i connected to you know eddie murphy or
right richard pryor you know um robin
williams you know i would i would i
would look at these comedy routines and
then all of a sudden i wouldn't say what
they're saying
but the essence of the way they
delivered it would show itself up in
something else that i would be doing
that may not at all be connected but the
essence of whatever that needed to be i
would try to drive that into that scene
um
wow
how cool too that you went at from the
positive standpoint of comedy versus the
negative is that just the way or you are
or is that uh or can you identify where
that came from was there was there like
a heaviness in the house that you wanted
to lighten up was it your was your
brother serious like did you just choose
that lane uh based on environment or was
this is this just very innate i think i
think it's mostly innate i think it is
it is a large part of just who i am as a
person um
in in growing up you know my brothers
and i we fought all the time like
physically yes all the time right we
were three boys my oldest brother is
three years older than me so right and
there's three of us so we were a bang
bang bang
and at that age it's like you're
constantly wrestling you're constantly
fighting you're constantly arguing right
there's there was a lot of that in in my
in my house and
like i used to always say like in school
i became famous because i was in the
principal's office
when a phone call came in about a
broadway show called the tap dance kid
because i had just been in a fight
right so i i was that kid right i used
to always laugh because when i would see
you
right at races and somebody might hit
you and take you out and i would see you
just storming down pit lane ready to go
take on some dude who's who's twice your
size and i was like yeah i recognize
that person
right i was always the shortest kid in
the class i was the smallest guy right
but i used to always say yeah you might
win
but you but you're gonna have to fight
to win
and you better watch your ankles
okay okay yo i'm gonna hit you straight
in the gut um but
but like that was something that i dealt
with but i but i was still a bright
light i still was like no we're gonna
try to like have fun and i always wanted
to have fun but but you know kids can be
mean sometimes and so i i literally i
fought three times a week in grade
school um
it was just part of what it was and i
used to always say yeah but you know
what you i'm gonna try to make sure you
never do it again because you know what
the end result is gonna be the end
result is gonna be that you're gonna be
in a fight so you're not just going on
you could have gone mma good well
you could have gone a whole different
direction yeah but they would have
needed a little pee-wee mma league
categories
yeah you know but i was thick so
i still had the weight just not the
the physical side